the most important financial rule for
entrepreneurs so got a great question
from one of my youtube viewers love you
guys
Albert wrote in the saying what tips are
financial discipline should I adopt as
an upcoming entrepreneur this is a great
question and Albert the number one the
most important financial rule that you
need to adopt as an entrepreneur is
don't spend money until you're making
money it's easy to spend money ok
anybody can spend money you are really
good at spending money right if I gave
you a million dollars today you could
find a million different ways to spend
money not everybody can make money and
that's the key difference as entrence we
don't start off with a lot of money ok
at least I didn't if you've got some
rich Uncle Joe who's willing to back
everything that you're doing and dump
all his money into your company then
fine do whatever you want but if money
is important and you don't have a lot of
it you guys it's got to be used properly
and wisely like it was for me then you
have to make sure that you're spending
it properly ok so a lot of entrepreneurs
do this say hey I'm gonna launch a
t-shirt company so I'm gonna go out and
I'm gonna buy a thousand t-shirts and
spend all my money on that and you end
up with a thousand t-shirts sitting in
your garage because you picked the wrong
product or I'm gonna go out and I'm
gonna start making videos and I'm gonna
get my own camera and I'm gonna buy all
the all the tools and then you get bored
of it after two weeks and you stop and
you got this equipment just sitting
there in the corner that's what a lot of
people do they spend whatever money they
have trying to get something to go but
it was the wrong vision it was the wrong
product it wasn't the right thing for
them and now you're out of money or
worse you go and you take out a loan to
try to make this thing happen maybe you
put an extra mortgage on your house and
now you're forcing this monthly payment
back that you can barely afford let me
give an example so with my with my
videos okay I make these videos right
you watch them every day hopefully when
I started my first videos were just with
my my DSLR camera
that's how I started I didn't want to
spend any money on it until I knew that
I had a way to make money and then I was
committed to keep on doing it and then
as I got a little bit of money from
advertising and as I saw some results
and I got a little bit of speaking gigs
here and there I could justify spending
more money on it and spending more time
and I knew I wasn't getting bored of it
because sometimes you start something
and then you get bored of it and you
invest all those money into it so it
started spinning a little bit more and I
started upgrading my camera and I kept
the cheap I went to Costco and my first
camera was gonna be 250 bucks 300 bucks
and I slowly started upgrading my
cameras through Costco and I always went
to Costco because you had 90 days to
test it out before we had to return it
whereas with the camera stores they only
gave you seven so if I didn't like it
and I didn't use it if I stopped having
an interest in it I could always just
take it back and get my money refunded
so I slowly started increasing my budget
as I started seeing results and I knew
it was working and I knew I want to
continue it so now how much have I spent
I spent $3,000 on my current gear setup
I have my camera I got my tripod I have
my microphone maybe a little over 3,000
I have Christina who edits my videos hey
Christina
I've got Monsour who does some research
for some of our video so I was a team
around me so I have salary to pay that
goes into making these videos happen but
this has happened because I've invested
along the way into making my product
better as I got results any company that
you start you can start small you can
bootstrap it up to prove that one you're
still interested in doing this and two
you find a way to make money at it if
you can get those two things happening
then it's easy to justify putting more
money into it okay putting any money
into it I think back to adventure
capital days and the easiest deals to
fund were the companies who just needed
expansion capital right so in other
words they'd already built up a business
they'd already proven their market maybe
they were only selling in their local
area and now they wanted
take it nationally and they needed
marketing dollars to do it that's the
easiest kind of money to raise and they
take the the least amount of equity from
you because it's not as risky right
because you've shown that it works you
shown that it works on a small scale and
now you want to build it out that's
worth spending some money on the hardest
money to raise is the R&D the
early-stage the pure startup because
it's just an idea and who knows maybe
you'll maybe you'll get tired of it
maybe you'll try it for three months and
then decide now this isn't for you or
maybe you'll make a ton of mistakes
because you've never done this before
you haven't figured out the right
business model and you have to pivot and
pivot and pivot and pivot until you find
it and I don't want you wasting your
money all along that path so the number
one most important financial rule for
entrepreneurs is don't spend money until
you're making money believe those are
watching like the video you can support
me by clicking in the link in the
description below leave a comment let me
know what you think and click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon